[Musik]
diesen ersten dich irgendwie diese
ganzen gerüchte von wegen ja auch hier
kati und man nun ja irgendwie getrennt
dieses jahr kaum
sie sind eigentlich gar nicht mehr
zusammen also generell bin ich jemand
den sowas nicht so trainiert weil ich
einfach denkt ja wenn etwas nicht stimmt
du bist du jetzt irgendwie eine krasse
auswirkung einer schau mal was sagen das
habe ich auch gemacht aber so
unersetzlich ansprechen ich ja auch
gegen haye gegen diesen an den haye
gegen body schäden und wird auch gegen
dieses immer mit dem finger zeigen auf
andere komplett aus also ich versuche
auch dass sich der anderen mut machen
weil sowas darf man gar nicht an sich
heranlassen das sind einfach gerichten
die nicht stimmen dann muss man sagen
nein das stimmt nicht
und dann auch wenn man irgendwie zu den
held oder würde kommentare wo kommt das
sind einfach den gibt's sollte man sich
nicht so herzmittel war wichtig ist dass
man selber wirklich ist und wie sind
glücklich wir haben unser lebens mutter
so wie es eben von uns passt und nur bei
man hat vielleicht nicht der norm
entspricht oder halt und canet so könnte
man es auch formulieren es ist noch
nicht fertig ist doch viel schöner wenn
wir alle kunden sind und auch ein
beziehungen wurzeln daran einfach so
lebt wie es vor einer besten passt
[Musik]